you know Jason Patrick who we all love
great actor when I said you worked with
Jim say give me something
yeah and he said when we did that
champion season uh Championship season
on Broadway that his father late father
Jason Miller wrote
you and Jason had a pre-show routine
asked him what it was
oh that's so funny
well it was to take uh I mean Jason
Patrick let me set this up to people
that don't know
you know all right so I'm in my 50s are
you in your 50s 50. yeah
there is something about
um there's a last message of
guys in their 50s and let me see if I
circulate articulate this that
are liberal
open-minded
but they also have kind of this
rap their they have the last remnants of
the Rat Pack
and of like guyish stuff and kind of
um
but we you know like you have to
understand that Championship season
which was my first play not even my
first Broadway players my first place
that
um and it was it was a play that I had
read I I was pretty much self-educated
uh I studied Finance in college and then
I graduated and I essentially started to
read
I mean I had a minor in English but I I
educated myself on theater and you know
I studied Meisner and all that but
and I love that Championship season and
it really is this analysis of
masculinity and and the 70s and and kind
of race and kind of
I mean it's a really important play yeah
um and um
and it was but are reachable to answer
the question is before the
before we would do the play we would
have a shot of Jameson which is such a
Jason Patrick thing
and I remember thinking I don't want to
do this
I don't want to do this but like if
you've seen the player you read the play
there is like this
there's this and you know like it's been
confused because there's a toxic
masculinity that we're dealing with
today but there is also something about
this
masculine Because by the way in that
play was Jason Patrick Kiefer Sutherland
Ryan Cox Jesus
Chris Noth and me so I was the biggest
of all
and by the way I was a college athlete
you know what I mean so it's like and
and these guys had all achieved
incredible success now I would say that
Brian Cox is probably more famous now
yes than he was then but he was
I think he had won an Olivia award yeah
well regarded well regarded yeah and so
it was so interesting because
um
there was
uh
there was five egos
an incredible play
the playwright's son was in the play
yeah it was on Broadway and when we
would go out and we would start the play
you have to understand this is after 24
was so like 24 was still in people's
memory and Kiefer Sutherland was the
biggest star
it was powerful you know it's pack
crowds yeah packed crowds it was also
when uh
Chris knoweth Mr big was still I mean
gigantic and I would say after every
single play every single night we went
out for a drink and often it would end
up
being a mess so we drank like we were in
college we drank like those guys Drank
in the play every night so some of it is
like anyway I mean it's great but it's
also one of those things where
people may not realize this it's like
you know actors find the character
within themselves but they there's a
morphing into you become some of that
character and the community becomes that
character uh becomes their characters
and it was uh
it was so interesting because
there's also something of
I don't think that
you know it was the beginning you know
it was I guess 11 years ago
um because I have a son because my wife
was pregnant every day and came to every
performance too
during that when it was the beginning of
um you know there's been different ways
of political correctness but like there
is like the n-word said in this play all
these things
but like
the audience was fine with it but the
critical
even though this play had won the
Pulitzer Prize
um
it was shocking
so it was shocking in that people
couldn't get Beyond some of the language
and so it was we were so knee-deep in it
in understanding that
um this was the language that was used
in Small Town Pennsylvania the the you
know the anti-semitic references it was
it was used it was much more of a
reflection of their insecurities than
being
uh portraying them as racist or
anti-semitic but I think that the
audience and the audience today would
not be able to
separate that right yeah I do
it's it's really interesting and uh
it was so fascinating because you think
of like the the good stardom that these
guys had tasted
oh yeah and the stardom that
and the theme that brought people to the
odd brought people to the show
I think that it was almost a disservice
to the play